good morning everybody welcome to
another edition of entrepreneur we need
a better name for this guy's I am talk
with league in the morning game we'll
figure something out yeah this is Q&A
featuring Rishi kept TV rishu off my
board thanks Evan hi everybody happy to
be here we also have the one and only J
reyez whoa in the house we are doing a
duo queue game Rishi what is in the cup
today you are going to die there is no
cup before me right now that's why I'm
gonna die well actually yeah you I
probably shouldn't say that right before
your league of life legend game but
thank you for the for the vote of
confidence there you are going to die in
this game I'm just really I'm feeling a
little cup of strange because I have
nothing in my cups this morning I mean I
have love for believe nation in my cup
but other than that I've got no coffee
because if you remember a couple weeks
ago I got sick and it's been very
strange like I haven't been able to
drink my coffee as regularly and
sometimes when I do I start feeling a
little nauseous Wow I know so I'm really
right now I can only do super high-end
coffee like if the coffee isn't like
from a really high-end barista and I
have found that I start feeling a little
sick so I didn't get to go this morning
to my high-end barista I'm uh I'm
allergic to mediocrity too I love it
what's in your cup evan i have i have
five cups in front of me that is kind of
thing my voice cracked as i said
that uh oh my god i have a cup of nettle
tea with honey i have a cup of soon or
protein shake and a cup of smoothie big
that's a big cup and a cup of pickup of
water and oh we got a game in a big cup
of tea from last night that Nina made me
with her Minnie Mouse man where's the
Minnie Mouse face so yeah I got lots of
teeth Wow drinks we're ready to go
alright Jay rises mid I am jungle we got
the synergies ready to go I'm excited
let's put it back looking for good all
right okay first question oh you know
what I had the first question I had
worst question I've been thinking I've
been thinking let me know what you guys
think we got reach NJ answer here I've
been thinking of two things I've been
thinking of potentially making this a
monday to friday stream Oh of doing a
morning game and I know you know if you
guys enjoying it soft if you can't
that's awesome too well that's a figure
it out I love it and I'm thinking about
doing a morning gratitude stream on the
channel on the YouTube channel like a
hangout hmm one of the things that I do
with with the with the leadership people
on my team is every morning we have the
facebook group we were private Facebook
group and every day during a week you
you have to leave three things that you
are grateful for in the group and it's a
great way to set your day you know if
you look at any happiness research
gratitude is always on the list of
things that are important so I'm
thinking you know that's really helped
me and it's really help the people
who've been part of the group and I'm
only thinking how do I give more love to
believe nation how do we
this out more so I'm thinking that's
like a short like a 10-minute warning
stream everyday i whine like I don't
know if I had to figure out the timing
where I share something for like a
couple minutes and then whoever's in the
comments sticking share some stuff or
weeded out recognize give a little
public praise to and then everybody
moves on good day i love it super high
leverage so it's a commitment its
equipment so anyway it was a two thing
i'm thinking of it of a monday to friday
league stream in the monday to friday
gratitude stream it's a lot of
commitment but did somebody take a vote
are you holy cow somebody took team oh
I'm gonna play Evelyn ah okay Evelyn
Evelyn was our monster was our
experiment last time and did well so
we're gonna go Eve anyway yes I put you
off Rishi what's up no that's okay no I
thought you said Monday and Friday
you're saying monday to friday only to
friday every monday full nap evans 11
the league league session yeah that
would bring us 25 26 videos a day on the
channel I'm just can't help it ah i'm
addicted to the i'm addicted to the to
the growth and the value here absolutely
i think i need to like literally start
playing llegan i think that old think i
need to get more involved in the game oh
there you go that's that you guys to
know if anybody rides that's it that's a
stream I rishis chain of jerez helping
Rishi know right that will be awesome i
know in my hands a house like a
playstation earth at something though
he's even cuter just a computer good six
it's a free game when you see the
computer oh it didn't like it yeah okay
when they have it okay anyway so that's
my thought a day to daily streams you
know whatever level commitment you guys
want to keep
I'm you know honored by but it's a plate
I'm still thinking about it and thinking
about is the feeler is the feeler
episode think if that's what we're gonna
do or not so that's my question that's
my question why I got it I got to make
changes to my calendar to to adjust to
make that happen so nice yeah anyway so
that's what I got let's get into the
questions yeah okay all right let's do
this we've got our first question from
ashley ashley is um has this idea to
start a business for trick o atilla
mania and Tripucka lemania is the
disorder where people compulsively pull
out their hair pull out their hair one
thing yeah have you ever heard of that
Evan I have not but i'm i'm i'm curious
yeah i remember when i was in middle
school there was a girl she used to like
pull out her eyebrows and her hair and
so it's like it's an actual disorder and
he wants to do this but she has no
experience and one of the things that
she was considering was doing tony
robbins business mastery program and the
program her concern was that it was a
fee that she wasn't sure she was willing
to pay for it if she didn't think it was
the right thing for her and and yet she
just wants advice and feedback because
she wants to do this but she has no
skills but she doesn't want to try to do
it without guidance but you know doesn't
know if it's a good thing to go doing
you know pays a paid mentorship program
that text with things
all right well I got it I got it so I
gotta share the love for Cody I have to
say I'm a fan of Sonny Robson um so
absolutely I would say you're never I
don't think there is if you really feel
like you know you you're being guidance
I don't think there is anything wrong
with doing these programs and I mean for
me at least Tonia's has enough of a
history where it's not like you're
worried you're going to get skinned I
mean the guy produces results and I
think that there's something to be said
about you know investing in what it is
that you want to do and so I don't think
there's anything wrong with that that
being said I also know that there are
ways where you can get training without
spending money and so if you're feeling
unsure about this program and you don't
think it's right for you then I mean you
are not let you are limited you are only
limited by whatever your mindset is that
you don't think you can do it with
without you know this or that we talk so
much on the this particular stream about
us so not about your resources it's
about being resourceful so I i think
that one great way that you could start
getting guidance without spending money
is can you find someone in the business
that you are in so that you're wanting
to be in and can you weather maybe you
could start volunteering for that person
or ideally even working for that person
so that you can become a experience in
the business before you venture out and
try to do it on your own and so I
absolutely think that there are ways to
find the experience that you need
without spending up
a big chunk of cash but hey if I had a
lot of money if I had like eight G's
sitting around I wouldn't I wouldn't
necessarily be kind of fun to do this is
fast trading program what do you think
Evan yeah oh wow wow they're invading
their that jungle skirted it's down
there um I you know I hate spending
money telling making money just as a
rule like I'm a big Tony fan we're gonna
have him on the channel or we're looking
to do it no lab like some kind of
interview or got a backing in the die
here um but if I i wouldn't spend my I
wouldn't spend my money on it until I
had a way to make money like for anybody
might you know myself included you know
like if I had some business mastery
program or whatever or the book or you
know anything that I'm doing I wouldn't
I wouldn't recommend that be like if
that's your last dollars i wouldn't i
would go out and make sure that I'm
surviving um you know the only cabinet i
would throw in is if you feel like
you're gonna regret the decision right
like if you feel that like Tony will do
this multiple times it's not a
once-in-a-lifetime thing and he has
amazing content and I believe in
investing in yourself and you know
there's a lot of positivity there I just
would not I as a principal and as a good
discipline as an entrepreneur it's good
not to start spending a lot of money
until you're making money
just I just don't I don't I don't like
that idea personally I'm not a family so
you know like whether it's whether it's
tony or anything else um i don't i don't
i'm not a big fan um I just gotta kill
with with some J reyez love and support
their so feeling the gratitude but it's
great to one invest in yourself and I
would look at what are some other
options where you don't have to go and
spend money whether it is a like the
idea of volunteering or working for
someone who has done something a lot of
times the resources like there's videos
of Tony that you can find no we put up a
number of videos of Tony you know you
might be able to go to the library and
get some DVDs or go to the library and
get some books of his and it may not be
as perfect and it may take a little bit
more time but that that's what I would
do just I think it's a good discipline
to get used to and if you have you know
if it's eight thousand dollars or
whatever it is plus travel and hotel and
all that stuff I I would not I would not
spend that until I had a little more
certainty over what I was doing my
business and maybe I'm just to risk
adverse on that but I think I've seen
too many entrepreneurs not only fail in
their business because they spent too
much money to rly but also really
negatively impact their lives and you
know go into debt to do this thing that
they're convinced is going to work and
then doesn't and now they're paying off
a debt for you know the rest of their
life and that kind of I'm scared on on
their behalf so yeah so I'd be looking
for other ways to accomplish a single if
possible
great well next question comes from it
oh and shout out to the to the live chat
today we've got a ki khabar in the house
best they know in the house so just a
little bit of love to y'all I love that
chair i just got a double kill so things
are looking good in this game hi guys HT
bar and z no I love it yeah and actually
he had a question and it's basically
said what do you think about being an
entrepreneur yes spending your time on
stuff like games and all I love it yeah
I think it's great I mean it I think the
more you can tap into the things that
make you come alive and have fun and you
know if it's just this same where you
feel like you gotta just you know be
rigid and serious and not do anything
else that we as human beings need to
just be whole human being I think that
you won't be able to sustain it so I
think the more especially as
entrepreneurs as hard as it is as lucky
you do have to work the more you can tap
into the places of fun and enjoyment
wool will always create a more happy
entrepreneur yeah combine the genius at
the end do the things that you love and
find the unique way to do it to others
are not so I like playing league it's
not my you know ambition to be a
professional league of legends player
anytime soon but i like it and be able
to combine that with helping
entrepreneurs answering questions i love
it um and we were talking at the start
of this episode of doing it more
consistent than what we're already doing
so that's fer me I think it's actually
good lesson for entrepreneurs to not
like nobody's doing this how I'm doing
this right nobody's nobody's started a
string people starting streams around
leak on 10 how to be a better gamer or
entertainment like you know people are
just naturally funny and they have you
know gifts of comedy that they're
applying to league I'm doing my way
answering business questions and you
know maybe it's a hit maybe it's not
we're getting some good feedback maybe
this becomes some huge singer maybe it
doesn't but I'm enjoying it in the
adding value to the people who are
asking questions who otherwise I
wouldn't be getting back to so I've got
skarner here so I'm a fan I'm a friend
and I think more people should do it
cool he also had a helpful he was just
recommending for the game hearthstone as
a good game also for doing [ __ ] oriented
dream have you ever play hearthstone
I've never even heard of it I have not
yeah it's it's a card game I think you
build your own decks and then you're you
know challenging other people okay
there's a lot of difference there's a
lot of different games that you can play
just like there's a lot of different
businesses you can start right got to
find the one that's right for you I
haven't explored that one I'm I'm still
enjoying what I'm doing now so if i get
bored then maybe i'll move on she's a
suggestion alright cool next question
comes from David and David has a idea
for an app he wants to create a language
app where you go to a country and if you
don't know the language in that country
you could just type in what you want to
say push the country button and then it
will you know generate what the
translation is or for you and so he's
kind of
wondering what do you think about this
idea event is it viable so I thanks for
the question David and I would imagine I
did not look into this but I would
imagine that the language app market is
inundated and I I would just say number
one yes the idea is viable you know I
think you have to believe in your idea
and if it if it's something that you
feel like you really are really
passionate about then yes just the fact
that you are feeling like you want to
give value and you believe in this idea
makes it viable um that being said I
think that probably language apps is
probably very in undated like like
anything else in terms of language and
translation so I would you let make sure
that you do a lot of research beforehand
I don't know if you have any background
in these programming or anything like
that so it would be important that you
have the right people around you to help
you make this a reality and
differentiate your app so that you are
somehow standing out because again I'm
sure there are he is an app that does
something similar to this
oh no it's all love it's all love like
first of all like it doesn't matter what
I think about the business idea right
like any business can work any business
can work every business is going to be
hard every business gonna have
competitors in some case like big
competitors you know I was at
Microsoft's headquarters and they were
showing me a demo of skype or they went
to they brought in one of their guys in
with me like live in Seattle and one of
their product guys from France and the
guy was speaking English in Seattle and
the guy was speaking French in France
and skype automatically translated the
conversation like it was it was pretty
insane and the transitions provided like
I I understand French having grown up
with and the transition was pretty solid
like maybe a few words that were kind of
off but who is pretty solid zone it's a
big need it's a big market there are
tons of big players playing in it is it
a good idea yeah if you can add value
you know like there's a lot of different
ways that you can you can play it but
you need to be able to bring enough
value so that it's worth it so is it a
good idea like I yes but oh we're in a
big fight when a big fight j reyez is
getting kills everywhere here this is
insane and Dragons I right good yeah I
am I got three kills zero deaths and two
assists so things are working out um so
look you don't need is me saying that
this is a hot market or a good idea to
go and do it's like the worst reason the
golden start a business or anybody is
saying that this is right like you got
to feel it you got to be it you gotta
love language this has to be a major
problem for you personally you have to
have something new and different that
nobody has done before or you get in
there and you figure out that you know
what somebody's already done this before
you got to find a way to now stand out
and be different and this is generally
applied to every business right like you
don't need anybody's permission to do it
and you better have enough insane love
for that you want to keep doing it even
if like go look at that skype demo does
that does look at that then make you
feel like oh I can't do this because
Microsoft is doing this right like so
what like tons of people had a YouTube
channel before I started buying I'm
still gonna go and get mine regardless
oh I'm gonna die I died very sad what
was Morgana doing that was crazy didn't
even pay attention anyway I should have
paid attention I died um it's very sad
so right like every industry has tons of
competition every industry has
established players there's this not
like this not this insanely easy
business that you should go out and
start and is a path to riches and you
can make money in any industry as long
as you can provide value so I only like
I hesitated Emily at the start because I
feel like I answer the same way a lot of
times but yeah but it's it's it's true
like if I go and say yeah man a language
app is the best thing ever that's just
really bad advice I fam and just as just
as similar if somebody says it's a bad
idea like if your mom thinks it's a
terrible idea if you desert this
language Apple that's not the reason to
stop doing it either um so there you go
happy Friday when he well you know Dana
was also saying in the comment you know
like another huge player is google I
mean at this point when I'm searching
for any translation I just google it so
you really have to know what why you
want to do this because yeah I didn't
even know about the skype thing but I
know Google is pretty much my go-to
relation so sure and and absolutely and
at the same time who cares right like if
you have a thing that you want to make I
don't care if Oprah has done it before
or Google or you know anybody right like
don't be afraid of being competition
just do it your way and do it
differently and do it better Yeah right
so that's what your app has to be able
to do did you just watch my video from
last week no you said I did not my video
less no my video last week was how
overfill my big idea oh do we need doing
you guys talk Rishi do we need a key do
we need their dressing mom I guess it's
just the point that if you don't like it
like you're just saying there there is
no new idea everything is absolutely
been done before so at some point you
have to decide what you are you have a
strong conviction in your heart to say
and to how you want to get value and
like you're saying it doesn't matter if
someone else does it it's you know do
you believe in it you got to do it so
and no one will do it like you do it so
I know that that sounds maybe a little
cliche but it's true when when I was in
the venture capital business we would
never sign a nondisclosure agreement
because so many people would have the
same idea like you think your idea is
unique you think your your business mine
is so special you know 3000 companies
out there in the same position as you
with the same exact idea and so I could
venture capitals will never sign a
nondisclosure agreement cuz they see too
many similar companies the difference is
the ones that like you bet on the person
you bet on the the jockey right you
think well this is the person who is
going to win the race because they're
going to adjust because they're
committed to it because they have the
passion for it's not the idea
right that's never the idea that's it
okay thanks thanks for the Phoebus good
analogy Oprah but at the same time like
somebody will steal your idea to write
like you better go out and get yours
because if you don't do it now did you
use no blame Oprah that's on You Man
like not not Rishi you all kind of its
getting mad at me this morning oh we got
a kill oh man now we're getting we're
getting attacked it's getting pretty
crazy um but it happens to a lot of
people like they they they have an idea
they think it's going to be amazing and
then they they don't do it they're
afraid they sit on it somebody tells
them they're they're not capable
whatever whatever you know reason they
don't do it and then somebody else goes
out and makes a ton of money on it and
they say that person stole my idea or
they blame and you know they blame their
best friend for not supporting them are
believing in them it's it's nobody's
fault but your own it's not Oprah's
fault it's not your mom's fault it's not
your best friends fall it's your own
fault for not believing in yourself and
doing it it's not my fault for telling
you it was a crappy idea or a good idea
it's all on you now go make a decision
hey I feel like feel like that might be
harsh but it's true I like it don't it's
all out of love for them not making the
wrong decision right I'm just blaming
other people you know you want something
you go get it yeah and also like I mean
oh we're continuing on with this one
question but like also like there's a
level of you having to be willing to not
feel like there's a perfect decision to
make like you know they mean it's part
of it if like tell me what is the
perfect decision that's not going to
fail and some of the
it's just something you can't even you
got to just try and you know even if you
fail its unto something maybe else that
will work so I think we get stuck in
this okay to be this or be that I have
to know which is going to work and I
don't think anybody really ever knows
you know yeah all right all right moving
on next next question comes worship
Kyler Skylar's developing a
multi-generational app and this in
theory is something that Skylar wants to
develop so that it says can
significantly improve our global
societies weakening state of morality
and but Skylar says I know next to
nothing about creating a business I'm
writing to you can you give me some
advice so we've got another app question
and well I guess again I for me go with
apps it goes back to just if you're
going to do this go for it but just make
sure that you also if in and of yourself
you don't have the background in
programming or developing something like
this then it would be important that you
can team up with someone who has that
because like you know it's a compelling
idea but you know how are you going to
get it done practically and it would
sound like you would really need to work
with someone it does not to the
experience that you have personally I
agree i think a lot of people are
romance by the idea of an app but they
don't know how to program and if
want to have success long-term success
in that field you have to you need
somebody on your team who can do it
right you're like if you are not the
programmer there's no massively
successful app company that doesn't have
a programmer who really loves
programming so maybe that is like maybe
that's him but he doesn't have the
business acumen or business skills I
mean you know that's what he's trying to
figure out right um so Jay do you want
the blue is that we're going for here
okay I'm gonna help you get that you can
do it there um I'm just helping J reyez
get some extra resources there to make
him stronger so like the collaboration
here ah so I about like happen
high-level kind of meta thought and then
it may be more practical thought I was
asked on the stream yesterday um what's
the most important skill you need to
have in business and and I mentioned
like passions always my go-to advice of
what's the most important thing in
business but I don't really consider it
a skill maybe let's just move on it but
it was yeah I was the willingness to
learn it's the if you want to learn
something you'll go out and find a
solution that's a huge part of
entrepreneurship like here's a goal I
have no idea how I'm gonna do it but I'm
gonna figure out a way so that's y a
massive a point that you have that
intent that listen I want to send an
appt company you got a great programmer
I have a great idea that i really
believe in but i have no idea
don't die I've no idea how I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna go out and research and I
will find a way and having that mine
said that you know I I take that mindset
into whatever I'm doing like I may have
no idea us our YouTube channel I've no
idea how to record videos I have no
friends who done this with me before but
I'm just gonna figure out a way to do it
and when you go in with that mentality
you can easily find sleep so this is a
guy example like hey reaching out and
saying to me right I need advice um
that's a great start but don't end there
right continue your journey to go out
and learn now maybe more kind of
practical we've addressed the
programming side like if you can do it
or not if not go out and find the
partner that can help you do it if it's
more the next part the next part comes
like marketing and passionate I'd be
looking at who has the audience right we
talked about a lot on the stream but
influencer marketing find the people who
already have your target islands and how
can you work with them to explain what
you're all about and get their support
in promoting your app with those two
really it's so easy to spread an app and
we talked about this on our last stream
I think I asked you what you have on
your phone yeah Rishi right and you know
you're all about snapchat and it's
awesome and what you're going to find is
when you have something that people love
they will share it so you've got to find
out what it is that people love we are
writing like there we go nice kill we
got word we're rocking this game and
this game is almost over I don't wanna
get too kind of cocky on this but this
is the same you're doing well on this
one um like if you can get people you
don't need a million people to download
your app what you need is a hundred
people to download your app and for them
to love it if that happens
then you'll get the million people to
download your app so pay attention to
your customers you don't need to have
like business is not that complicated
provide value you will make money you
will have an impact right make something
that people actually love and care about
right and want to use it doesn't have to
be this big scary thing and so if you
get some some people downloading it then
just really pay attention that
experience and make sure something that
they want to use consistently over and
over and over again and and the next
time you're and maybe you know broader
message everybody else the next time
you're concerned or afraid or like you
don't have the experience you know
there's always a way he's always a way
there's always a way go figure what I
way is there's always a way yeah we got
rice and cut but not realizing the chat
we got rising the game Annika the man is
multi multi talented multi tasks tasks
tasks did I don't know he doesn't man I
have our time just keeping up with
what's going on here I'm answering
questions it's true it says business
that he said business is not that
complicated provide value make money
that's what you just said Evan good
quote that was a tweetable moment that
wasn't home and I'm glad I'm glad I'm
glad you're feeling it rises everywhere
I see it Xena Rises everywhere alright
next question comes from SE pehle were
they i think felony la la i think i
don't know if I'm singing it wrong but
alright tell a penny says um I want to
make a living by working online let me
give you the best easiest and fastest
way to work yeah Billiat market yes
and yeah he says he wants to work from
home and he wants to be able to do it
online what can you recommend i love i
love it well we get this we found this
question before I think the I think we
all want to have the fastest easiest
best way to just work you know from home
and have the life we want to live and
all of those really attractive luxuries
but I think going back to our last
question like if you're really really
interested in doing something that's
going to kind of create the life that
you want it's going to start by you
providing value and I think it's easy to
just say can I find an affiliate
marketing and how can I just set it up
going you know we got the question left
Wednesday passive income like how can I
just you know make money so I can live
the life I want but it's just kind of
void of the substance like the question
is leaving out some of the more
substitute factors like what do you what
do you want to do and how do you want
provide value how do you want to make it
so that other people are other people's
lives are getting better because of you
nothing wrong with you know wanting to
be interested affiliate marketing and of
course there's plenty of ways to do that
a lot you can blog and use affiliate
marketing can be a youtuber use
affiliate marketing so I think the
greater question is what do you want to
do how do you want to provide value and
then affiliate marketing can be a part
of that but a quick fast easy way to get
money so you can live you know all the
life of luxury that you want is I just I
don't know and maybe there's some some
other person out there who'll tell you
what that is but i don't i don't really
believe that that's that the way to go
well we won the game is over Wow yeah I
was fast we rocked it we were activated
the nine kills one death and forces so
pretty pumped about that um I feel like
we address this question a lot and I
already talked about it earlier kind of
on the screen I'm just thinking like
extra contacted by that I can add one I
would not be searching for just the
short term quick fix because it's likely
going to bury you deeper than where you
were before and the person who promises
you that and sells you the
five-hundred-dollar course or fifty
dollar ebook or whatever and will take
your last time because this is the
opportunity of a lifetime here those are
not the people to listen to and and I
get the frustration and I get the sense
of despair and you can do things you can
have a big picture and I can take a
while to get to and there are smaller
wings and smaller goals and ways to
support yourself that tie into your
bigger dream but it's got to be around
something that again you are adding
insane value to and I'd be looking at
but I feel like marketing can work it's
it's just a business model there's a ton
of business models network marketing
ecommerce affiliate marketing direct
sales like it's just it's just a way of
selling something and so for affiliate
marketing to work some people love it
some people hate it it doesn't really
make a huge difference it's you have to
have an emotional attachment to the
product or service or selling it's got
to be something you want to recommend to
your mom it's got to be a product that
is
you know not just the exact same as
everybody else I need to figure out how
you're going to go and sell it is it
going to be just a website are you're
going to go knocking door-to-door you're
going to be joining clubs and networking
with people and trying to let them know
what you're all about and are you good
at that like is that the best
combination of your skills and if you
want to be able to make money quickly
then it's about providing value quickly
and what is the best combination of your
skills and talents to be able to lead
you to provide value quickly so if you
you know like if look at affiliate
marketing if that means you have to go
and set up a website talking about your
products well are you can you make a
website are you good at dad you know how
to drive traffic to a website or say it
means you're going to go out and go to
meetings and network with people and let
them get to know you and you're you know
gonna chitchat and build rapport and
build a bond and then they're gonna
you're gonna tell them what you do and
try to sell whatever processor versus
you have well are you good at that like
do you like going to networking meetings
do you are you good with people because
any of those models if you don't have
the skills then you can learn them if
you're passionate about it you can learn
them but if you're trying to make money
quickly you need to think about what is
the best combination of the skills and
knowledge and resources you have to
provide value quickly to potential
customers and that's much more an
exercise of self-awareness because I
don't want you to buy into some
affiliate marketing course which then
hows u doing a whole bunch of stuff that
you don't know how to do and don't love
and you're selling products that you
don't use or care for like that will not
work for you that's not successfully in
the hole because you're trying to find a
way to break through financially
and so the you know my frustration or my
bluntness is really out of a genuine
care and respect for your time because I
want you to make sure you're not going
down the wrong path wasting more time
spending more money and not getting any
more closer to the results that you're
seeking so what is the best combination
of the skills resources knowledge that
you have now to be able to add value to
another human beings life that's your
fastest path to making money as an
entrepreneur and that maybe affiliate
marketing me but maybe it's not maybe
something totally different and and ye
did self discover and have the awareness
to be able to figure that out you said
it again Evan what is the best
combination of the skills I just made
that up on the spot me she got me voted
it there you go what is the best
combination your skills Oh passions i
think that i think i think i said skills
resources and knowledge great look any
passion it's jen with it when is all
that stuff right yes passion skills
resources not only trite like what do
you have do you know that can help
somebody else out add value to their
lives without having to go learn
something totally knit like if you want
to start an appt company and you don't
know how to program well kick you want
to learn how to program like if that's
your insane desire you want to be a
programmer awesome go and do that figure
it out take the courses dive into it you
know the willingness to learn that we
talked about it's great we've got it but
if you don't then that's not the best
combination of your your talents your
skills your passion to be able to add
value and you're going to get stuck on
the programming side and so do you bring
on a partner or do you do a different
business idea right and too many people
don't have that self-awareness and they
get locked into you know somebody system
or somebody's program there's ten step
formula in
like each of those steps don't apply to
them so okay there you go guys i love
you i am happy okay i feel like this
harsh love that comes out on these these
chance but but it's it's just really a
genuine frustration that I don't want
people to fail right like eight hundred
ninety percent of businesses will fail I
almost failed in my company I wanted to
quit I don't want I know how hard that
is and I don't want people to stay there
or to get there but they haven't gone
there yet right so young love LS so I
turn out okay ah this is awesome thank
you guys for watching Thank You Rishi
for the advice thank you j rise for the
collaborations and ingame energy and
in-stream chatting to finding a way to
do that i will sit on the daily stream
idea see how we're going so stay tuned
for either monday or wednesday for our
next dream um that's all I God thank you
guys for watching thank you who is in
life child see we got we got Zeno rise
me yay who's the other one who joined in
htn bar kippa our HT khabar have an
amazing rest of the week rishi got a
final message i'm just going to say what
is the best combo of your skills and
passion to provide value quickly AKA
what's in your cup whoa a new angle of
meta there I like that Jay you got a
message a final message yeah keep rising
keep rising all right that's it have a
great weekend guys continue to believe
or whatever you
one where it is and we'll see you soon